[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing hogwarts legacy
the upcoming harry potter game that
boasts an open world format
that we haven't had in the harry potter
games of the past
the trailer was released on the
playstation youtube channel last week
and people haven't been able to stop
talking about it since
the main reason for this it looks like
it may be the first harry potter game
that has been done right an open world
single player
action role playing game which will
allow you to create your own personal
witch or wizard
and spec them exactly as you want them
to be but one thing that fans are now
asking is
how familiar is the environment of
hogwarts legacy going to be
sure we know hogwarts and we know the
magical world
but the game is supposedly set in the
late 1800s
exact date to be confirmed so i expect
that it's going to be presented
in a different format the game takes
place around 100 years before harry
potter starts attending hogwarts
and we the player will run through the
game as a student of hogwarts school
of witchcraft and wizardry during the
late 1800s
this time frame introduces one very big
question
how familiar is the wizarding world
actually going to be
adrian ropp head of story at avalanche
software
who are bringing us the game alongside
portkey games had this to say
the portkey games label gave us a unique
opportunity
to return to hogwarts during a different
era we are always asking ourselves how
we can draw from the rich library of
characters
creatures and themes and imagine how
those details would influence the school
more than a century before harry
potter's arrival who was the headmaster
what challenges did students face what
influenced their society before tom
riddle
before newt scamander i like to say that
what we are giving fans
is something familiar in a way they have
never seen what this tells me is this
avalanche and portkey are approaching
the harry potter universe
from their own new unique perspective in
an effort to introduce concepts
ideas characters and creatures that we
aren't already familiar with
they don't want to deviate from canon or
existing law but they want to explore
the unexplored
simultaneously giving us something new
to think about while answering some of
the questions that may have been
lingering in our minds
since the books and films were first
released rop continues
we embrace what we know and challenge
ourselves to expand upon it
nearly headless nick would have been
floating around loyal and cheerful as
ever
the forbidden forest was still forbidden
and home to centaurs
not likely keen on human interaction
goblins were rounds but this lot
certainly didn't work
at gringotts the village of hogsmeade
was there and in ollivander has been
making ones
since 382 bc often the difficult task
is choosing which details we aren't
going to explore this cements the fact
that many of the elements
of this game will be familiar to us
whether those elements appear in the
form of places
creatures and characters the only thing
that isn't certain
is which elements the game creators are
going to dive into further
it seems like the creators of this game
are really dedicated to creating an
authentic experience and i think a lack
of authenticity
is what has historically been most
off-putting to harry potter fans
case in point the cursed child which
contradicted so many aspects of the
wizarding world
that we had already solidified in our
minds over the years
the worst part was that it did so in an
almost haphazard way
when the first book came out i became an
instant fan this
is a labor of love and the real magic
comes from the dedication
and imagination of a team who wants
nothing less than to make this an
authentic
and compelling visiting world game rop
continues
sometimes i stop to appreciate the
surreal nature of my story meetings
how should this character's voice change
when they drink polyjuice how long do
ourselves live
are grab horns omnivores these are the
types of questions that drive us toward
authenticity
and the types of questions you only
think to ask when you have steeped
yourself in the law okay so now that
we've confirmed that we're going to be
seeing some familiar places
characters and creatures the next
question that needs to be answered is
who are we likely to see the game takes
place in the late 1800s
and this should certainly help us to
narrow it down in a previous video
i discussed whether or not dumbledore
would appear in the game so you should
check that video out for a more in-depth
explanation
however given that dumbledore was born
in the year 1881
and that he began attending hogwarts in
1892 i think that it's highly likely
that we'll see the former hogwarts
headmaster
in some way shape or form whether he's
an integral part of the story or not
similarly grindelwald who was born
around the same time as albus dumbledore
may appear in the game though i expect
this is unlikely
given that he would have been attending
school in a different part of the world
another character that i'm almost
certain we will see is sirius black's
grandfather
phineas nigellus black who served as
headmaster of hogwarts until the year
1925 when he died
given that the game is centered around
well hogwarts
it would be highly unusual if we didn't
see him another former headmaster of
hogwarts that we may see
is armando dipit who succeeded phineas
black as headmaster
however given the time frame i expect
that we will see
armando dippid in some kind of teaching
position another character that we may
see
who is a bit less close to home is
garrick ollivander's father
gerbild ollivander who ran olivander's
one shop before garrick
olivender's one shop is a diagon alley
staple for students who are about to
embark on their journey to hogwarts
so i expect that we may be seeing him
quite early on in the game
what characters are you guys hoping to
see in this game are you excited for it
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time
your wizard hurry